[Musique]
la fameuse taxe santé de 200 $ c'est
fini de cette année en 2017 et le
gouvernement pour l abolir de façon
rétroactive à 2016 lors du dépôt du
budget de québec mardi
reste que cette taxe destinée à financer
les établissements de santé après la
crise financière vous a coûté cher
depuis 2010 mais 100 dollars si vous
gagnez entre 42 me les 130 mille dollars
jeu non
[Musique]
la mise en place d'une contribution
générale dont la santé cette
contribution santé vise tous les adultes
québécois à l'exception de clientèle à
faibles revenus
koné de l'oxygène ou ta mine en
abolition la taxe santé
mais vous savez parfois les promesses en
campagne électorale de nom l'abolition
de la taxe santé uniforme et son
remplacement par une contribution santé
progressive à compter de 2013 et je
crois qu'il faut maintenant remettre les
pendules à l'heure et ella elle l'a
ramené au niveau zéro je vous confirme
[Musique]
l'abolition complète la contribution
santé
dès janvier le 1er janvier 2017
et si le gouvernement a aboli la taxe
rétroactivement à 2016 selon les
informations qui circulent un
remboursement pourrait vous attendre
après la production de votre rapport
d'impôt ou l'année prochaine
à quelques mois des élections le
gouvernement libéral parlera d'une
réduction d'impôt du fardeau fiscal pour
les contribuables les partis
d'opposition ne voit pas la chose du
même oeil
il estime que cette taxe instaurée par
les libéraux n'a jamais eu sa raison
d'être
[Musique]